Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies and
germs. This is Tim Ferriss. I'm happy today.
I'm happy because I get to have a conversation
with my friend Seth Godin. Seth is a frequent
flyer on this podcast. For those of you who do not
know who Seth is, Seth Godin is the author of 21,
count them, 21 international bestsellers —
you eclipsed the fingers and the toes — 21
international bestsellers that have changed
the way people think about work and much
more. I'm going to add that on my addendum.
His books have been translated into 38 languages,
and Seth's books include Tribes, Purple Cow,
Lynchpin, The Dip, and This Is Marketing. Seth
writes one of the most popular marketing blogs in
the world, and it covers much more than marketing,
I should say. And two of his TED Talks are
among the most popular of all time. He's the
founder of the altMBA, the Social Media Pioneer
Squidoo, and Yoyodyne, one of the first internet
companies. So he's seen many chapters, many
moons. His new book is The Song of Significance:
A New Manifesto for Teams. You can find all
things Seth at sethgodin.com and seths.blog.
Seth, so nice to see you.
Seth Godin: Hey, Tim,
this is a great excuse. I would rather cook
you dinner, but this is a close second.
Tim Ferriss: I will take you up on both. And
I thought we would begin with what is present
for me at the moment. And you were very gracious
in being flexible with our start time. I went in
to see an ophthalmologist for the first time in
many years, and he also happens to be a surgeon,
but I wasn't going there for any type of
surgery and I did not anticipate when I had
all the drops put into my eyes that I would be
completely incapacitated for two to six hours. I
couldn't see anything within 12 inches of my face.
They gave me some throwaway glasses basically just
to get the job done so I could at least call an
Uber and get home. And we pushed our start time,
and the net-net of it was, "Your eyesight, like
everything else, is aging. It's still very,
very good." At least my distance is 20/15, which
is fantastic, but it's not what it once was,
20/10. And I had I want to say a moment of
crisis when he basically took a card and put
it in front of me while my eyes were blurry and
he said, "This is where your vision is going,
just so you know." So his bedside manner could
have used a little bit of work, but I wanted
to ask you how you think about or relate to
aging and the changes that come with aging.
Seth Godin: What a great place to start. I mean,
I was on the internet in 1976 before many people
listening to this were born. And when I started,
one of the first internet companies, there was no
World Wide Web. So the world keeps changing and
so do we. And it's very tempting, because the
stars in front of us keep changing and getting
younger, to imagine that we are sort of fading
away. And so my analogy, my dad taught me to ski
when I was 12, and I was terrible at ball sports,
not very good at hockey. I hated getting hit.
I broke my nose, I broke my arm. But skiing, I
was a maniac. There were no helmets in those days,
but no one could get down the hill faster than me.
And when I was 16, I fell under the chair
lift at Sugarbush on the ice and skidded
the whole way from the top to the bottom, face
down, head first, dislocating both shoulders
and ended up needing surgery on both.
The first one was botched by a neighbor,
the second one was by the doctor for the US
Ski Team. And I said, "I can't ski anymore."
But when my kids came along, I taught them
to ski and I got back into it with my dad.
And then I realized when I hit like 35, "You're
just going to have to keep confronting the fact
that you're afraid and you're not going to get
better at this." So I switched to telemark skiing,
which is twice the work and half the speed. And
I did that for 10 years. And then I switched to
skate skiing with Nordic skis. And I get to still
do that. And it's very easy when I think about my
lack of recall that I used to have where
I could run a seven-hour session without
repeating myself to my inability to ski anymore,
to 17 other things that I'm walking away from.
And to feel a sense of loss, to feel like we need
to grieve that we're not that person anymore.
But I guess after my first bout with COVID, it
was more like, what a gift I have today to be
in the shoes of somebody who, at 62, gets to
do things well, but only because I'm walking
away from things I can't do anymore. And
instead of focusing on what I used to have,
I'm really working hard and getting satisfaction
out of focusing on what I do have, what I can do.
And that just raises the stakes for things. And
the reason that this is interesting, I think,
is because boomers, and I'm a little bit,
I'm a lot older than you, but boomers have
driven our culture since the day I was born.
When we were draft age, that was when the draft
really mattered. And when we were listening to
rock and roll, that's when music really mattered.
And when people needed to make money for their
family, that's when Wall Street really mattered.
And now boomers are dying. And so we are living in
a culture where there's an overhang of all these
people with loud voices talking about the end of
the world because it's the end of their world,
but it's not the end of the world.
Tim Ferriss: I thought you might have
a few things to share on this subject.
Seth Godin: That was a rant to get us started.
Tim Ferriss: My goodness, you just bought
permission to talk about whatever you want.
That put a salve on my existential crisis wound
that I had earlier today. But before we move on,
let me ask you, on a day-to-day, week-to-week
basis, you strike me, and have struck me for a
long time as a, let's say, default optimistic.
Generally, if we consider baseline to be
emotion-neutral, generally above-baseline person,
are there times when you catch yourself perhaps
focusing on noticing, dwelling is too strong a
word, but ruminating on the loss of something?
And in those cases, what do you do? I'm just
wondering what the intervention looks like,
what the self-talk looks like, anything like that?
Seth Godin: So I really wish you had had a chance
to interview Zig Ziglar.
Tim Ferriss: Me too.
Seth Godin: Zig was my friend. He was one of
my first teachers. And one of the things I took
away from Zig as someone who had gotten himself
into a pessimistic cycle for five years early in
my career is the world is going to be whatever
the world is. Approaching it with a positive,
energetic attitude probably will make
your experience of the world better
than girding yourself by being a pessimist
and maybe getting what you're hoping for.
So I find myself coming back frequently,
particularly in the last bunch of years when
there's been so much doom and gloom to this idea
that we get to pick our attitude. And in fact,
it's the only thing each of us truly gets to pick.
And it doesn't mean what happened to you
is what you deserve. It just means that that
happened. Now you get the one and only choice,
which is how to process that. So that's not the
answer to your question, but that's my approach.
But I would find myself in negative ruts
when I'm confronted by too much media. When
I first started organizing The Carbon Almanac,
there was a full two months when the cataclysm
that we have created was confronting me really
directly, and it was hard to find my footing.
Tim Ferriss: Speaking of response and choosing
response, and I don't want to shuffle the deck
in such a way that makes things difficult, but
we spoke a little bit before we began recording
about the several thousand things that we could
discuss. And one name came up, which was Viktor
Frankl. And would this be an opportune time? We
can always hit snooze and come back to Viktor.
Seth Godin: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: But
would this be an opportune time to invoke the
name Viktor Frankl and let you run with it?
Seth Godin: There are a few books that have been
brought up on this podcast more than that one,
and Viktor Frankl's story, survival of four
concentration camps, just generous, heroic.
The thing is, a lot of people stop reading
halfway through the first book that they
touch of his because the story is really powerful.
But then you get to this stuff about logotherapy,
and some people say that he was
part of the triad of Austrian
pioneers in the way we think about the mind. There
was Freud, who focused on sensuality and sex.
There was Adler, who focused on status, dominance.
And then there was Frankl, who focused on meaning.
And meaning, as far as I can tell from my limited
reading of Frankl's work, is when a human being
finds a thing that means something to them, a
chance for a path forward, a pathway to hope,
everything in their life gets better.
And that his work, he lived for another 70 years
after he got out of the camp, 65 years, his work
in suicide prevention was extraordinary from the
statistics I've read because he understood that
for many people, I'm not generalizing everyone,
but for many people, finding a path toward hope
of meaning, of realizing that the struggle is
the struggle, but you get to decide what to do
with it, is really profound. And I think as our
industrialized world has gotten more narcissistic,
which basically says, marketers need to make you
uncomfortable so that you will buy more stuff
to feel better about yourself and your standing,
marketers are trying to push people
to find meaning in purchases.
And the problem with that, also in friends and
likes and social media nonsense, the problem
with that is it doesn't scale. And after you've
got one storage room full of stuff, buying more
things doesn't seem to help you find more meaning.
And I really feel like we're in this moment in
our culture, this moment in time, where people
are waking up and saying, "Thank you very much,
but I don't need to buy another thing. What I
need to do is find something to care about."
And I'll finish this with a two-parter about,
I went to see a community orchestra last week.
My friend is in it, all volunteers. And the thing
about community orchestras is there are violinists
and flutists and oboists who get paid money to
do it, but no one in the community orchestra
is saying, "Why aren't I getting paid?" Because
that's not why they're there. In fact, they often
pay to be there. And I'm guessing, with no data
whatsoever, that if you survey people who are in
community orchestras, they probably index happier
and more engaged in life than people who aren't.
And so the question is, where are we going to
find our community orchestra? For me, the last
year and a half, it was The Carbon Almanac. I
had 1,900 friends in 90 countries around the
world. I ran into a bunch of them yesterday
in Union Square. And they're not doing it for
money. None of us got paid. They're not doing
it for me. I wasn't even there until I showed
up at the end of the day. They're doing it because
the meaning that they get from it is so valuable.
It gives them a reason to put up with all
the other stuff they have to do every day.
Tim Ferriss: I think we should take a
moment just for those who are not familiar,
to provide a little bit of background, just a
brief description of what The Carbon Almanac is,
and then we can navigate from there.
Seth Godin: So as you so generously said,
I've written 20 books. I wrote Permission
Marketing, which invented the business of
email marketing, and I wrote a book called Purple
Cow, but I don't need to write books. I don't wake
up in the morning the way I used to saying
"What I do for a living is write books. What
should I write about now?" I only write one when
I have no choice. And two and a half years ago,
I read the magnificent Ministry for the Future by
Kim Stanley Robinson, and it completely upended
the way I saw the world. It was astonishing to me
how much I didn't know about what was happening to
the climate. And I realized that I wasn't talking
about what marketing and corporations were doing
to the climate because I felt stupid. And the
reason I felt stupid is they wanted me to feel
stupid, that they want us to be confused.
And I thought, well, if I'm underinformed,
I bet other people are too. And I used to make
almanacs for a living. I did The Business Almanac,
The People Magazine Celebrity Almanac. I
know how to make a complicated, long book.
But I realized A, it would take me too long
and B, it would be really lonely. So what an
opportunity. I downloaded Discourse, set
it up, invited some people to join me,
and within a month we had 300 volunteers,
most of whom I have never met in person.
And in 150 days, we built, edited, footnoted,
researched, copyedited, illustrated a 97,000-word
book with no errors in it — all as volunteers
around the world, 24 hours a day, trading shifts.
And the process of building it found solace
for all of us. And I learned so much,
which I incorporated in the new book about what
a community can do when people are enrolled.
And I also learned a lot, like plastic
recycling is a fraud. And Exxon
knew long ago about what was happening to the
climate. And my favorite is that carbon footprint,
the concept was invented by Ogilvy and
Mather for their client British Petroleum
as a way of getting privileged people to feel
guilty about their behavior. And if you feel
like a hypocrite, maybe you won't speak up.
Tim Ferriss: So where should we go here? We
find ourselves at a multi-pronged fork in the
road. We can talk about industrialism, we could
talk about building community, which is something
that is certainly on my mind, but I don't want to
hijack. I could try to coax and direct, but I
don't want to hijack if it's not a natural place
to go. We could talk about creativity, trust,
enrollment. I'm choosing a few words here and
there that come to mind. AI, of course, on many
people's minds. But perhaps you could speak to
the antidote to nihilism. And I want to
preface that just by saying when you talk about
marketers and corporations, I would like
to say, and I think it's fair to say that
you come from the place of someone
who has worn the hat of marketer.
You come from a place of someone who has worn the
hat of founder, of executive, and therefore I give
it much more credibility than I would someone
with 27 bumper stickers from 27 causes driving
around in Berkeley who's never really worked
in an office or in a business of any type who's
spouting off about the evil corporations in the
same way that someone might talk about the evil
Illuminati. So that I want to establish. With that
backdrop, could you speak to how you think about
nihilism and addressing nihilism?
Because certainly even in my audience,
and particularly among younger people, but I
have seen it bleeding upward into my generation,
even people who are older than me, what appears to
be this creeping nihilism, this sense that nothing
means anything. You can't sort true from false,
right from wrong. Everything's too confusing.
We have deepfakes, misinformation, disinformation.
You just can't sort anything from anything else.
And on top of that, it seems like the Titanic
has already hit the iceberg. We're on the way
down. You can't really patch the hole. So is
the best we can do playing violins on the deck
while she goes under? Or is there anything
else to do? That is maybe an overstatement,
but not much of one. This is something that I
really do sense in many interactions that I've
seen and felt. And I would just love to know how
you have thought about that, because I have found
myself similar to where you found yourself
perhaps at one point with The Carbon Almanac,
in a malaise. And some would say, "Well, it's
a well-warranted malaise. So what are you going
to do about it?" And I would love to know what
you suggest we do about it or what you have done
about it, aside from the putting together The
Carbon Almanac itself. Longest question of all
time. Thank you for listening to my TED Talk.
Seth Godin: It's a great question. It's a
great question. And you should be driving
because you know exactly what's going on.
I'm going to start by saying I'm a hypocrite and
so is everybody else. And so I don't have to point
out that I'm more pure than other people because
I'm not. And now after just a few minutes of the
podcast, we have to put onto the table a very
simple statement, which is we're all going to die.
But that was true 50 years ago too. And there's a
great book that I loved called The Last Policeman.
I'm not sure I'd say it's a great book. It's a
great concept, and I really loved reading it.
Imagine that there's an asteroid
that's going to hit the Earth in
a year and destroy and kill all of us.
It's not Don't Look Up. It just starts with that
premise. And then it's a police procedural book
about the last policeman left in a little village
in New Hampshire, because everybody else says,
"Screw it, we're all going to be dead in a year."
So marriages break up. Why would you go to
work to clean the fryer if you know you only
have a year left to live? Supermarkets fall
apart, but he goes to work every single day.
Because we're all going to die, maybe not
in a year, but no one listening to this is
going to be alive in a hundred years. Even some
Silicon Valley billionaires who are getting blood
transfusions aren't going to be alive. Right? And
so the only question is, are you going to die in
a year or a hundred years? And when we look at
the data on the climate, it's very clear that
there are going to be 10, 20, 30, 40 million
climate refugees every year. That whole swaths
of the Earth are going to become uninhabitable.
It's not going to be pleasant for many people.
Can we "fix it" and go back to, I don't
know when? No. Is it a problem that we
should address? Definitely. But that doesn't
mean we could do anything to live forever.
So given that we're all going to die, the
question is what's the point of tomorrow?
And for me, I think the key question coming at
this as someone who went to Stanford Business
School a very long time ago is some people believe
that the purpose of business is to enable culture,
to enable humanity. And some people believe that
the purpose of humanity and culture is to enable
business. And I think those people have too much
influence right now, and they're wrong. And Milton
Friedman just made up this nonsense about the
only purpose of a corporation is to maximize
its profit. It lets people off the hook and they
become tools of a system that grinds stuff out.
So if we think about Amazon, Amazon has had
turnover as high as 30 percent in a 90-day period.
30 percent of all the people they hired across
the whole company quit in less than 90 days.
The data that I quote in the book is that
it costs Amazon a third of their profit,
a third of their total profit because of turnover.
And the reason is simple, because when you get
there to work in a warehouse, and more than half
of all the warehouse industry injuries in the
United States happened at an Amazon warehouse
last year, they don't treat you like a person.
They say your job is to beat the numbers on
this sheet of paper or on this iPad screen,
and then beat them again tomorrow. It's Frederick
Taylor on steroids with a stopwatch jerking people
around — the expression jerking people around
came from Ford's assembly plant in the 1920s
because Frederick Taylor and Henry Ford used
a stopwatch to measure every single motion.
And a visitor to the Ford plant said, "It looks
like everyone here is wound up the way they are
jerking from left to right with strings pulling
them. It's a wonder that they can even live."
And when we think about tomorrow or the tomorrow
after that, given the damage we've all done,
we still live in culture, we still have this
miracle. You and I are talking while thousands
of miles apart, we have access to every piece
of information. We have magical computers that
can understand us and talk back. We can reach out
to someone in need. We can connect to people who
need to hear from us. And if you want to just give
up because the world is going to be different in
20 years, that's your choice. But given that we've
got this window, it feels to me like we need to up
our focus on humanity and connection and
possibility and improvement of the condition,
and maybe not worry so much about public
demonstrations of power, firing people online,
being brutal in the service of profit.
Because we don't have a profit shortage,
we have a meaning shortage.
Tim Ferriss: So what can someone
listening do? You could personalize this to me
if you like. I'm always looking for meaning,
it seems to be a perennial subject for me. What
can someone do if they're listening and thinking
it is not my path, or I don't have the
bandwidth, or fill in the blank to become, say,
a climate activist. Not to say that's what you're
implying, but what else can I do to be part of
the light and not part of the dark, so to speak?
Seth Godin: Yeah. So in a minute, I want to talk
— sorry, let me let that — so in a second, I want
to talk about the bees, but first, significance.
So I surveyed 10,000 people and I said,
"Tell me about the best job you ever had."
And I gave people 14 choices about what made it
the best job they ever had, including, they paid
me a lot of money or I didn't have to work very
hard. And the results were the same no matter
which country people came from, no matter how
old they were. The results were, I accomplished
more than I thought I could. People treated
me with respect and I did work I was proud of.
If we feel significance, we start to feel
optimistic. We start to feel meaning. We start
to feel human. Where does significance come
from? It comes from making a change happen.
Can you be really clear about the change you seek
to make and who you are making it with and for?
So when I think about climate, most of the people
who showed up to work on The Carbon Almanac said,
"Well, I'm doing fine. I recycle this, I compost
that. I don't do that." And this is the myth of
the carbon footprint. There is nothing you can do
personally, as a privileged person of the colonial
world, to fix the climate. But what you can do
is organize, that if you can figure out how to
get five or 10 people together, you can probably
ban gas-powered leaf blowers in your village.
And that will have 50 times the impact of you
switching to an electric car. Plus the idea
of banding together with five or 10 or 15 other
people, creating the conditions for other people
to find something to care about and succeed at
it, will fill you with meaning, not with despair.
But leaving the climate aside for a minute, when
we think about our days where we go to work,
who we work with, whether we're in a community
orchestra or not, is it significant? Is it about
you and the change you seek to make? Or
are you, quote, "I'm just doing my job."
So I'm doing a talk for Harvard. And
they said, "What do you want to call it?"
And I told them and they renamed it, which I
got them to unrename, to "Having Your Employees
Feel Significant," as if it's some sort of hand
waving that you get to do with the free snacks.
And that's not my point. My point is, we built all
these systems so we can actually be significant,
so we can actually point to what we made.
So let's go back. How long ago was the
first breakthrough book for
you, 10 years give or take? 15?
Tim Ferriss: Last breakthrough
or the first breakthrough book?
Seth Godin: The 4-Hour Workweek?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, The 4-Hour Workweek
was 2007. So let's call it 15 years ago.
Seth Godin: 15, 15 years ago. So what
you said to people, to a lot
of tut-tutting and disbelief,
is that you as an individual have access to tools
so that you can find something or somebody or some
system that can do the grunt work, so that you can
actually do human work that is valued by others.
And that opened the door for what so
many people are now capable of doing.
However, there's still all this pressure to
race to the bottom. If you put your freelance
work on Upwork, the race is to be the fastest,
cheapest person. Well, if you're the fastest,
cheapest person, you're just a Mechanical
Turk. You're just cranking it out and no one
cares about you because the minute someone's
faster and cheaper than you, they'll switch.
And what we're looking for is to find
work where our work is unmistakably us,
where our work is something we can point
to and say, "Given who I am and what I see,
I made this. I made this for you. Can you please
help me make it better?" And when we can do that,
our days are totally different than when
we're basically sure that an AI is going to
take over our job for free as soon as the boss can
figure out how to write down what we do all day.
Tim Ferriss: So let's just say,
as a thought exercise, that
you came across through, doesn't have to be
through altMBA. You end up taking on as a mentee,
the 25-year-old current day version of you,
similar background, similar education. How
would you help that Seth to do this?
Seth Godin: So I haven't run the altMBA
for a long time. I'm very proud that there's a
B Corp and it runs and lives happily without me.
And I don't have any official mentorships.
And you've heard me talk about this before
because it just doesn't scale and it
becomes this bottomless pit of repair.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, this is
just a total thought exercise.
Seth Godin: But I need to say it, because
sometimes people hear your thought
exercises and then they send me notes.
Tim Ferriss: Seth's thinking mentees.
The Subreddit, "Seth's Mentees."
Seth Godin: The point of my work is
for me to be able to be a mentee without showing
up in person. And I'm thrilled when that happens.
When someone sends me a note saying, "I'm 25 years
old, how do I become a marketer? Where do I get a
job? Where do I train?" My answer is, "You do it
by becoming a marketer. Go find a charity that
you care about and go raise $10,000 for them.
Go to a garage sale, buy $40 worth of stuff and
sell it on eBay for a $100. Go figure out how to
tell a story to somebody else that changes them.
And if you're a receptionist at an
ophthalmologist's, you can do the
same thing. You can figure out how to take that
person, the patient who just came in or is on
their way out, and make them feel 10 percent
better by saying something, doing something,
interacting with them. Not because it's in the
manual, not because you memorized it, but because
you see a way to connect to another person. If you
can do that just a little, you can do it again."
And that is the breakthrough that industrialists
do not want us to understand, that they invented
public school so we would say, "Will this be
on the test? How little can I do and still
get picked?" And all three of those things
are wrong. And the option instead is to say,
"Is there a human somewhere connected to you
in person or online? Can you connect with them
in a way that makes things better for them, at
least a little? And then can you do it again?"
That's what culture is. That's what
we've been doing for 10,000 years.
That is what fills people with meaning. And you
don't need tips or tricks or hacks. Like someone
sending me an email saying, "Seth, what's your
favorite color?" Because then if I write back,
somehow we've built this sense of mutual
connection. No, that is not marketing. That's
hustling. And hustling doesn't work anymore
because everyone's doing it. And just wait
till the AI spam shows up. The AI spam is going to
make your head explode because it's going to be so
effective until you end up not even trusting that.
Tim Ferriss: Right. So putting AI spam aside,
I agree with you. I mean honestly, I'm just
enjoying my current level of spam while I can.
Tim Ferriss: But if people are listening
and they want to, as you've outlined,
create meaning, do human work, not succumb
to a race to the bottom where they end up
replaceable by the next fastest, cheapest fill in
the blank, do you have any other guidelines? Do
you have any other guidelines besides get
started, do the thing that you are aiming to do,
or any other reasons to be optimistic?
I think that might be helpful also just to
not level the scales a little bit. But I feel
like optimism is often a precursor to action
or a prerequisite in a sense.
How would you speak to that?
Seth Godin: Okay, so —
Tim Ferriss: And I want to footnote, I did take
a note on paper. You said, "I think we're going to
come back to the bees," if I heard you correctly.
Seth Godin: We're going to come back to the
bees. We are. Let's talk about the boss.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Seth Godin: It is entirely
possible that you work in a place where you
have no options. You have no agency. You have no
significance. If that is actually true, you should
quit, because you don't get tomorrow over again.
My guess: it is not actually true. My guess is you
have more agency than you are prepared to embrace.
And so go start a book club at work. Start
with one of Tim's books. Read it with four
other people. And so get on the customer
service line after your shift is over and
answer three questions. And so figure out how
to engage with someone in the organization
in a way that is not part of "your job"
and figure out how to lead and connect.
You can do those things without getting fired.
Or after work. A friend of mine got married at
an old folks' home and the person, the witness,
was 97 years old, and two days later she passed
away. So do you think that that's going to be
a magical marriage to have honored that person,
the one thing that she was staying alive for
that she got to see before the end? Or do you
think it makes more sense to be a bridezilla
and to just make sure you're part of the
wedding industrial complex and everything
matches everybody else's wedding? Right?
So in all these elements of our life, we are
pushed to do something the normal way, the
profitable way, the way where we are blameless.
Or we can choose to do something that matters.
So now the bees, if you don't mind.
Tim Ferriss: I don't mind.
Seth Godin: I am fascinated by the bees. So the
story, it's more personal than most stories I
tell, but I have been hoping to share it with you.
So I'm glad we're getting this chance to talk.
I've got to note I don't fly for work anymore
because airplanes feel like cannibalism to me
after working on the climate thing. I feel like I
can do my work without doing that. And after 1,000
in-person speeches, I've earned the right to say,
"No, I'm not going to get on a plane anymore."
But I needed to get somewhere for family reasons.
And someone reached out and said, "For family
reasons, I have built a firm that's remote. I'm
really remote in Australia, because my daughter,
who's 10, was born with some health problems. And
I've tried to organize our lives to support her
in having the most magical life that she can. And
I'm running a conference for the entrepreneurs.
My venture firm funds, they're all in regenerative
work. They're all dealing with the climate problem
from a commercial point of view. Will you
come help run a two-day seminar for them?"
And I happened to be somewhere near there. So I
said, "Yeah, I can do that." And so for free, I
showed up to do this two-day workshop. Well, the
day before he reached out and said, "I'm not going
to be there in person because my daughter's not
feeling very well, but I'm sure it'll go great."
So the person I ended up running it with is
a beekeeper from Australia. And he started
talking to me about the bees, and he told me the
story of Jacqueline Freeman's Song of Increase.
And The Song of Increase is just such a great
Tim Ferriss story. So here's what happens.
A typical hive, not the big honey hive. We
could have a whole conversation about big honey,
but a typical feral beehive at the end of a long
winter, will have barely made it through. That's
what the honey's for, to supply them with food
during the course of the winter. But if they
made it, the council of maidens will meet.
They're the ones who really run the hive,
and they will do a couple things. The first thing
they will do is build a vertical egg chamber and
instruct the queen to lay and fertilize a queen
egg, which is very unusual because there's only
one queen in a hive. And the second thing they
will do is tell the rest of the maidens to go get
as much pollen as they possibly can and replenish
the honey supply. This happens in May and June
in the Northern Hemisphere.
And so what will end up happening is
the hive will — this is 20,000 bees, will be
back in shipshape condition by June. And then
based on the weather, because they know what the
weather is going to be, they're very good at this.
They will organize without an organizer, leave
without a leader. 12,000 bees will leave the
hive in a 10-minute period of time. They will leap
out of the hive singing the song of increase. And
Jacqueline has written beautifully about this.
And then they end up in a tree 100 yards away,
in a tight ball, because bees have to
maintain a body temperature of 98 degrees
or else they fall apart. They get into a torpor.
And now they only have three days to find a new
place to live. And each one of the bees is doing
what the bee does. Almost every bee, except for
the queen, is only three weeks old, which I didn't
know. I thought bees lived a really long time. And
so the scout bees are doing their scouting and
the maidens are doing their — and each bee is
doing their thing. But the hive is basically a
human brain inside out. There are neurons all
working in sync to create this leap forward.
And hearing this story, I was completely
transfixed by what the song of increase could mean
to people. And then I realized people aren't bees
and we're looking for something with even more
internal meaning than simply this leap forward.
So I ended up driving then really far, hundreds
of miles, to visit a friend. And early the
next morning I went for a swim with all this,
forgive the pun, buzzing going on in my head.
And there was, as someone who swims almost
every day, there was a very fierce riptide
and I came as close to drowning as
it is possible for a person to come.
And as it happened, I was pretty okay with
the fact that that was the end of that.
I would miss my family. I would miss
so many things. But it was like,
"Well, if that's the end of that, that's the
end of that." And then this mission of talking
about significance just flooded over me and I
somehow figured out how to get back to shore.
And then the next day I heard from Dan
and his daughter Frankie had passed away.
And the combination of all those things helped me
realize that the world probably doesn't
need another marketing book from me,
but probably could benefit from thinking about all
of those things at once and realizing that we have
so much more power than we want to acknowledge.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you for sharing that, Seth.
That is more personal than most stories you've
shared. And I'll just take a beat on that and
would love to hear what happened after that
swim, after that phone call. What did the
next week or two look like for you or feel like
for you with respect to this germinating seed?
Maybe it was beyond a seed of significance and
shifting perhaps to a focus on that with your
communication, with your thinking.
What did the subsequent week look like?
Seth Godin: Right? It's funny. It's funny
because no one's ever asked me that,
but it fits right into the question you asked
a little while ago about what can people do?
I wrote a whole book in two weeks. I said, "How
can I honor Frankie? How can I honor Jacqueline?
How can I honor all of the people who are being
brutalized by billionaires in Silicon Valley?
How can I honor the climate refugees? How can
I honor everybody who has something to lose
by doing the thing that some people
think I'm good at? And what could I do
for Frankie that would be better than this?"
And so that's why I did it, because writing
a book, as you know, is more of a lift than is
rational. And I could have just written a few
blog posts, but having people see you do this
irrational lift helps them understand that you
have something important to say and that
maybe they'll share it with somebody else.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to throw out a few terms.
Actually. I'll give you two, two choices, and we
can go down whichever path you choose. Or option
C, which I don't present. You're good at choosing
option C when people say, "You can choose between
A and B." So that may be where we go. Wooden tiles
or Quakers. Where would you like to go?
Seth Godin: All right, so let's talk about — I
learned something fascinating about the Quakers.
The Quakers invented solitary confinement.
And when we think of Quakers, non-violent,
et cetera, the whole idea, think about the
word penitentiary, right? It's where
you go to be penitent, to repent.
And the idea of solitary confinement was to create
the conditions for people to get comfortable with
their sins and to repent from them.
And then across in England,
they built the panopticon, which was a prison
where you were under constant surveillance. So
this is super low tech. You just put the
guardhouse in the middle and make sure
the windows are all lined up. So everyone
feels like they're being seen all the time.
When we add solitary confinement to the
panopticon, we end up with surveillance
capitalism. We end up with this idea, not the
surveillance capitalism of consumers being
surveilled, which is what that book is about,
but more about workers being surveilled,
that we isolate them from each other, except
when they're in a Zoom call where the meeting
was designed to make sure they weren't picking
up their dry cleaning when they were home and
counting their keystrokes and measuring
their output and counting the clicks,
constant surveillance. And for many people,
the equivalent of solitary confinement.
Well, why are we surprised that turnover is
high and work satisfaction is low? Because we
stripped meaning from people when they go to work
because we don't trust them to be people. We need
them to be resources. And that's why the very
phrase "human resources" is such a challenge,
because after you've optimized the machines, the
next thing to do, of course, is to optimize the
people. And we are, there's the whole measured
self-movement about how can you get better on
your bike with Strava, but that's happening
to you at work whether you want it to or not.
Tim Ferriss: So let's just say you are the founder
of a small company and maybe it started off as a
solo operation or a husband-and-wife
team. And good news, you seem to have
created something that people want or need and
it's growing. So you hire. You hire people.
And you have the best of intentions. You believe
yourselves to be moral people, ethical people. And
that husband-and-wife team are listening to
this podcast and they have four employees.
Maybe they're in a fast-growing bakery — who
knows? And it could be any type of business.
They have the tiger by the tail. They're
growing quickly. There's not a lot of room
for under-performance, because a lot of
people are wearing a lot of hats. How
would you talk to those people? Because
they may hear this and say, "Yes, Seth,
I want to value my employees as humans, not
just resources. And the reality is we have
pretty tight margins. We're attempting to grow
quickly. We have a lot of inventory. We need
our employees to really perform at the highest
level possible. And if they're not performing,
we do need to let them go or replace them."
Seth Godin: Yeah. Okay. So we're going to do
an aside in a minute in my old voice about
freelancers and entrepreneurs and growing a
small company. But before we do that, I want
to highlight I am not here to say, "We need
soft to replace hard." I'm not here to say that
workers benefit when the boss goes easy on them.
In fact, I'm talking about the opposite.
That the significance of what can be built
by Cesar Chavez or what could be built by The
Carbon Almanac team for no money has nothing
to do with soft or hard. It has to do with the
idea that you make a promise and you keep it,
and you need to have a lot of rigor where
you are relentlessly criticizing the work,
but you are not criticizing the worker. You earn
enrollment on the change you seek to make. Right?
That the original Mac was built by 13 people
at a pirate flag and they worked harder than
anybody in Silicon Valley has ever worked before
or since. And they didn't get paid very much. And
if you talk to Susan years and years and years
later, I don't know if she's been on the podcast,
but she's great. She will talk about it
as being a seminal moment in her life,
right? Because they got something done.
So that's why we need to have the aside about
freelancers and scale. Freelancing is magic. I
am a freelancer. I used to be a freelancer. In
between, I was an entrepreneur. They are different
jobs. Freelancers get paid when they work. They do
the thing and it has their name or something like
it on it. It's very hard to scale freelance work.
What you need to do is strip away the busy
work, outsource it. And what you need to
do is get better clients, because better
clients demand better work and pay you more.
But what usually happens when a freelancer
starts to succeed is they hire junior versions
of themselves and try to push those people to
read their mind, work ever harder and faster
for less money than they get paid and then pass
it off as their work. That's super stressful and
it almost never works. And so if you really are
building something bigger than the two of you,
I would say, tell me this thing you were
building and why some customers will pay
more for it because you added human value.
Because if you're trying to out-Amazon Amazon,
you've got trouble. Even Walmart can't out-Amazon
Amazon. That's not a race you can or want to win.
So what we see is if someone is going to build
a bakery, or a wedding services business, or
a physical therapy facility, they can win by
racing to the top. By saying, there are people
here who do work you cannot find anywhere else.
But do not expect that you're also going to get
that work faster and cheaper than you can get at
other places, because you can't have everything.
And if you could make a promise to your customers
and your employees can see their contribution
to that promise, you're not going to have any
trouble at all, getting your employees to do
what they need to, because you created the
conditions for better. You didn't try to manage
your way into getting them to give you a bargain.
Tim Ferriss: So let me take a step off the
highway onto the footpath, the bike path,
on the side for a second, because this
is related and very self-interested,
but I'll ask it anyway since I guess this
whole podcast is pretty self-interested,
I get to have conversations with people I like
and respect. But you've known me for a long time
now. I would say I think that's a fair way to put
it. We've known each other for a decent stretch
and I consider you very good at being aware of
your own assumptions, the constraints that you've
applied to your life, choosing the rules,
choosing for instance, a story about money,
past a certain point, past the requirements, past
your basic needs and wants. Money is a story, so
choose a story you can be happy with, et cetera.
Is there anything you've observed over time with
me where you're like, "It's funny, Tim has this
conceptual limitation stuck between his teeth
all the time and he can't seem to see it when he
looks in the mirror. He's always got that spinach
between those two teeth and it bothers him. He
is always picking at it, but he can't quite get
it loose." This is a very long-winded way of
asking what are some of the maybe questions
or issues that you seem come up repeatedly
with me? Is there anything that comes to mind?
Seth Godin: I was completely wrong about my first
impression of Tim Ferriss. And that's because I
based it on people who didn't understand what you
were trying to do that to me. And so I was getting
hustled by people who said that you were the
person who was teaching them how to hustle and I
didn't bother to spend the time to understand what
you were actually doing. And that's completely
on me. And you have developed a voice and a
contribution to the culture and your community
faster and at a younger age than almost anybody
I've worked with and way faster than I did.
And I don't see any spinach in your teeth. I
think that it's unlikely that you knew 16 years
ago that you would be having conversations
like this, that you would've built this
platform and leverage you have
to teach so many people things.
But at the same time when the opportunities have
arisen, you have been really smart about saying,
"No, I don't want to be a judge on Shark
Tank," and, "No, I don't want to figure
out how to hustle people to pay me on
Cameo." You're saying, "I have something
to narrate here for people, whether or not I
know exactly what tomorrow's going to be like."
And it's not easy to do that regularly at the
level that you do it with the amount that you put
out. So I know you weren't fishing for me to say
this, but I've needed to say it in public because
in private, in my head for the first nine months
that I sort of knew you, I didn't really know you.
Tim Ferriss: I appreciate that, Seth, and I
should provide a little context for folks.
And the context is, when we have dinner
together on the East Coast, or I guess
it's always on the East Coast, because you're
very good at setting your geographic bounds.
I ask you for a lot of advice and you're very
forgiving and tolerant of me asking many,
many questions, which I really deeply appreciate.
So that question came from a genuine place and
thanks for the very kind words. I love doing
this. I love having these conversations and
there's absolutely no way I ever could have
foreseen this being my "job" 16 years ago. No way,
absolutely not. And I think probably four or
five years from now, whatever I am doing, then
I will have the same statement for "There's
no way I could have predicted now that
I would be doing that five years from now."
Seth Godin: And let's just — to broaden that out,
parents who have a sticker on the back of their
car have been indoctrinated to indoctrinate
their kids to do the same thing. To say, "Oh,
you studied mechanical engineering, so you're
going to be a mechanical engineer for the next
70 years and then you'll die." And that's not
what humans are capable of. What a joy to be able
to say, "I have no idea what I will be saying and
doing in five years." What a privilege that is.
Tim Ferriss: It is. I feel really fortunate.
Seth Godin: Can we talk about
false proxies for a minute?
Tim Ferriss: Let's talk about false
proxies. I'll let you lead the way.
Seth Godin: Okay, so people might be wondering
about the wooden tile. So I have a 70 watt
laser cutter in my basement. Doesn't everybody?
And so I make these things that are like I Ching
cards. And so instead of having notes or
something, I just really like the texture of
them. So that's what the wooden tiles are. And so
there's a wooden tile right here that says "False
proxies." We need proxies when we go shopping at
the supermarket, because if you're going to buy
ketchup, you're not allowed to taste the ketchup
before you buy the ketchup. So the label on the
bottle is a proxy for what's inside of it. And
we're even capable, as consumers, of figuring
out we haven't had this particular flavor of salad
dressing before, but we can guess from the other
clues that it's going to be good or not good.
And we use proxies to pick which restaurant to
go to, and proxies to figure out what book to
buy, because you're not going to read the book
until after you buy it. Judging a book by its
cover is a very common and important thing.
At work we developed proxies because we have
to hire people for a 20-, 30-, 40-year career
before they work for us. So one proxy is, "Did
you go to a famous college?" One proxy is,
"Are there any typos on your resume?" One proxy
is, "Are you good at interviewing?" But of course,
unless you're hiring someone to be an interviewer,
being good at interviewing is a false proxy.
And yeah, the thing about false proxies is they
lead to caste systems, to social stratification,
to prejudice, to misogyny, because we are quickly
making decisions on who to swipe left or right
based on clues that aren't actually related
to whether the person can do the job or not.
If someone is in a wheelchair, they
might be a great programmer. Whether
or not they're in a wheelchair is irrelevant
to whether they're a great programmer and yet
it's 2023 and it's still happening. So there's
all of this information that's now available to us
where we can look at the work instead of looking
at the proxies. So the simple solution, which
I've been lucky enough to adopt, is I won't work
with someone unless I've worked with them before.
And that means I will pay someone to do a short
project and I pay them whether they do a good
job or not. But if they're good at the project
now, I know that they're good at the project
because they did the project. And with all
of the stuff that's happening in our world,
with the rate of change that's going on, with
the need for people — not who know something
they learned at school, because they can look
it up online, at Stack Overflow in two minutes.
What we need are people who are resilient, and
risk-taking, and honest, and transparent, and
connected, and loyal, and all these other words
which don't match up with the proxies we usually
use when we decide who to hire, who to let into an
institution, who to reward, who to follow online.
So I think it's important to just name it,
there are false proxies in our life and they're
expensive. They get in the way of our output and
they also steal our soul and they denature our
culture, because when a proxy becomes important,
when for example, a celebrity gets the benefit
of the doubt, what we've done is we've handed this
person leverage that isn't really helping anybody.
Tim Ferriss: Did I hear you correctly,
Seth? And if so, I'd love to hear you
expand on this a bit, that you only work with
people you've worked with before. Did I hear
that correctly or was that a different line?
Seth Godin: What I mean is if I'm going to
do a project, the old way to do
it was to look at the 10 million
viable people, pick the one who has the shiniest
set of easily measured proxies, and hire them.
And I have hired hundreds of people that way. And
for a while I told myself I was really good at it.
And then I thought about it and I realized I just
thought I was really good at it, because of all
the people I didn't hire, because they didn't
match my perception of what I was looking for.
And what I learned, particularly working on The
Carbon Almanac, is everyone was a volunteer.
Everyone got the keys, take the car for a drive,
and if you did something that was really good,
we asked you to do more. And if you
didn't, we asked you to do something
different, because the work was the point.
And so now I'm working on this interesting
software pilot thing and I went to people who I've
seen do projects and who I've danced with before,
not based on where they live. One lived in
Nigeria, one lives in London, one lives in
Portland. "I've seen your work. I don't know you
personally. The personal stuff is an interesting
proxy, but it doesn't usually match. So let's
dance again." And once we can seek enrollment,
once we can say to the world, "I'm looking for
a freelancer who wants to make this change in
the world, this project is this size and I'm
going to pay you this much to do it," we can
use our human judgment to decide who to offer the
project to. But then when the project comes back,
this one-hour, one-week project, pay them
fairly and then decide based on the work product
whether it's useful. This is exactly the way
Matt builds WordPress. That Automattic is a
reading and writing culture where if you're
good at reading and writing, you get to do
more stuff. But there's no points for being
good in a Zoom meeting. No one gets promoted.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, no one, definitely with Matt,
no one gets promoted for Zoom meetings and you
do have to do some customer service, which
I think is actually a fantastic practice.
Even if you're C-suite, you get to spend a
couple of weeks answering customer tickets.
Question for you about employee retention,
and I'd love to hear you speak to your
personal experience. You've hired many
people, and this may not map directly
to the writing or the principles in The Song
of Significance — it may. But I'm wondering,
because hiring is one thing, retaining is
a close cousin, but not exactly the same.
And there are people out there, I know quite a few
people who are really good at putting in the time
to hire really good people, but they haven't
been able to, for whatever reason, as
thoroughly, as effectively, think about retention.
So they lose some people who are very, very good.
What have you found to be, in your
experience, or observing others,
some of the key ingredients or possible approaches
to ensuring that you retain high performers?
Seth Godin: So if we look back just 50 years,
the purpose of a company town is if you are the
landlord, it's much harder for someone to quit.
That the goal of the old school industrialist
is that your employees have no options,
because if they have no options, you
don't have to pay them very much.
Let's compare that to an ad agency. I read
a book about them many years ago called St.
Luke's in London. There were 30 people, they
won a whole bunch of awards. When you win a
bunch of awards as an ad agency, what happens
is you get a whole bunch of fancy new clients,
which means you have to hire more people, which
means the average goes down and then you get big
enough to, you've exhausted and you sell out
to Saatchi & Saatchi, and then you are done.
And the 30 of them looked at each other
and they said, "We don't want to do that."
So they made a rule and the rule is "We're never
going to be more than 30 people." They then said
to their clients, "That means we can't take
any new clients unless we lose an old client.
So they have a waiting list of clients and
we have a waiting list of clients. You can
go to your old clients with your best
ideas and if they give you a hard time,
you can say 'You're fired,' because I've
got another client ready to take your place.
And it also means that if you are only going to
have 30 employees, if someone wants to leave,
let them leave." There's a waiting
list of people who want to work there.
Turnover is a good thing when we are
doing human work, not a bad thing.
And what I would do if I was running
a real company is I would say
the first thing you've got to do on your first
day is update your LinkedIn page and keep it up
to date. And we're going to have a resume job
finding seminar every two weeks here. I don't
want you to stay here because you can't get
a better job. I want you to stay here because
the conditions we've created, the work we
are doing is worth you staying here for.
And then I would listen. If I'm not creating
the conditions where the people who I need to
be dancing with want to stay, I have to change the
conditions, not curse the people who are leaving.
And this permeability is where the future lies.
We don't have 40-year careers anymore. We have
four-month careers or three-year careers. So
onboarding is faster because you can say to
somebody, "Read everything in Slack, come
to work tomorrow, ready to start, because
it's all there." So now instead of onboarding
you in a month and a half, I onboarded you in
three hours. And because we're project-oriented,
turnover is a little different. And if I can keep
somebody here for a long time, it's because they
want to stay here. This enrollment is the key.
Mahan Khalsa has written a book called Let's Get
Real or Let's Not Play about B2B selling. But
the lesson of Let's Get Real or Let's Not Play
is simple. What promises are you going to make
this week? Promises about your career, promises
about your learning, promises to our customers.
Show us your work. We will relentlessly make it
better. This is how we're going to treat each
other. If this is the right place for you, I hope
you'll stay. And if it's not the right place for
you, I hope we can agree that it's not, but
seeking retention doesn't feel right to me.
So let me just elaborate on this book, because
it's overlooked and so beautiful. If you are in
business-to-business selling expensive,
committed items to large organization,
large organizations can now find out everything
they need without calling a salesperson.
So the intelligent, trained, expensive salesperson
benefits by saying to the prospect on the first
day, "Look, you've told me you have this big
problem you need to solve. You have a five million
assembly line that's letting you down, blah
blah. If we can solve this problem together, are
you ready to install our system? Because if it's
not real, let's not play. Don't waste my time, I
won't waste yours. You're not going to buy from me
because I'm going to take you to the golf course.
You're not going to buy from me because our RFP is
going to come in cheaper than somebody else's. You
want my valuable time? I'm going to engage with
you, and tell you the truth and you'll tell me the
truth. You're going to draw your org chart for me.
You're going to tell me other complicated products
you've bought and why your company bought them.
And I'm going to get you promoted by teaching
you how to buy the thing that's going to save your
assembly line. Let's get real or let's not play."
That kind of selling is how you sell a $10 million
product. You don't do it by spamming people and
pretending you know their favorite color.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, very true. This is truth.
Long ago in a former life when I had a
lot more hair and was just out of college,
was selling to CEOs and CTOs and you do not sell
expensive systems by guessing their favorite
color or even having that conversation. In
fact, it'll be really counterproductive.
The topic of sales makes me think of Zig
Ziglar. And I'm wondering, just out of my
own personal curiosity, were there things that
come to mind where you disagreed with Zig,
maybe you respected his position or a
principle he had, but you personally did not
embrace whatever it was that he used as part
of his own script for navigating the world and
people. Is there anything that you disagreed on?
Seth Godin: Many things, and we did it as
friends. So it's funny, Zig has come up
twice today before you brought him up,
which is weird. I sent a picture of him holding
one of my books to someone just four hours ago.
Zig was my teacher from afar for a long time.
I memorized more than 72 hours of his tapes. I
listened to the selling tapes until they wore out.
And then I bought another set and I saw him in
person a bunch of times and each time wrote him
a letter afterwards and each time he wrote back
and my letter would highlight the things that
worked and talk about the things that didn't. And
one of the highlights of my speaking career was
when he and I shared a stage in front of 22,000
people. It was pretty cool. And then I got to
publish his Goals book toward the end of his life.
Zig and I disagreed about astrology
and yoga because he was coming at it
from a different cultural point of view from
Yazoo City, Mississippi. And we were like,
"Okay, we can disagree about stuff like that and
organized religion and things like that." What was
interesting is when my understanding of permission
marketing evolved and Zig's key sentence of
you can get everything in life you want if you'll
just help enough other people get what they want
kept coming up, because he meant it two ways and
one of the ways didn't work for me. He would say,
"You can get everything in life you want if you
help enough other people get what they want," as
a way of encouraging self-interested, short-term
people to see that the best way to get ahead
was to do a favor for someone else because that
forced empathy opened the door to making a sale.
And what shifted for me over time was how
about you can get everything in life you want
and you can help other people get what they
want, but they're not one gets you the other one.
That what we have is the chance to hold
open the door and let somebody else go in,
not because we want them to give us something
in return, but simply because holding open the
door is, in itself, a significant useful
act that will fuel our next cycle of work.
And we talked about it a little bit toward the
end of his life, but what Zig did for a lot of
folks is help them become professional instead
of just hustling. And I also learned a lot about
living the life of the professional speaker, and I
could go on and on, but if your listeners haven't
listened to a bunch of Zig, yes, it's dated, but
you can find the good stuff and be glad you did.
Tim Ferriss: Where would you suggest people
start or what would you suggest they search for?
Because the universe of Zig, as you mentioned,
62 hours is a starting point. Where might you
suggest they start? What should they look for?
Seth Godin: The stories in the book Secrets of
Closing the Sale are gold. I could tell
word for word the story of the overalls.
And his original classic See You at
the Top, also filled with stories.
When I was starting out, I failed for seven years
in a row. It was a very long slog. And his tapes,
which you can still get today on CD, also
filled with nothing but stories, were
super dated even then, but so cheesy and
wonderful that if you listen for an hour
a day, you can't help but not quit.
Tim Ferriss: And to give us an image
in time. What were you failing at over
that period of time as you listened to
these audio cassettes and wore them out?
Seth Godin: So my first job was in 1983
at a software company in Boston. I worked
with Arthur C. Clarke, Michael Crichton, Ray
Bradbury. I was a brand manager. I was 24 years
old. It was spectacular. And then I left there,
moved to New York and started my own gig and
just kept failing at the book business. Chip
Conley and I did our first book together and then
I got 800 rejection letters in a row. That meant
every day I opened the mailbox and three people
had taken the time to write me a letter with my
name on it and put a stamp on it saying, "We don't
like your project and we don't like you either."
And it's very easy in the face that, and then I
was just pitching and pitching and pitching and
often in a way that amused me but was selfish.
And I was pitching to people whose job was to be
pitched. I wasn't calling people up on the phone
at home, right? This was the head of acquisitions
at Simon and Schuster, whatever it was. But when
the rejections feel personal, if you don't have
a way to keep caring, but understand that what
they're rejecting is the work, not the person,
it's super easy to give up. And that was the
transition that I needed to make. You didn't
like this idea. It's not that you didn't like
me. What can I learn from your criticism of
the idea so that the next one will be better?
Tim Ferriss: You strike me as someone who's
quite happy to have solo time, engage in solo
projects, maybe a project with a family member
or something else like building canoes. That
could be a whole conversation in and of itself.
How are you building? Are you building a community
orchestra for yourself at the moment or looking
forward in the short term to doing that? Or I
should say in the soon-to-be-present future?
And if so, how are you approaching it? Because
this is something that I've also noticed,
and this is not a brilliant insight,
but it seems to alleviate a lot of the
existential dread and mitigate some
of the nihilism that people feel if
they simply have some type of shared purpose
or activity with a few people consistently.
How are you thinking about that for yourself?
Seth Godin: This is just me. I don't know how to
broaden this to everybody. So the reputation I had
from the beginning was, I don't miss deadlines. I
never go over budget, and I'm going to deliver
you what I said I was going to deliver you.
And no one who has worked for me has ever been
part of a layoff. People have lost their jobs
because it wasn't a good fit. But I've never said,
"All you guys, we're downsizing." When Google
shut down Squidoo in one day with no
warning and no honest explanation as to why,
my eight coworkers and I all went down together.
But the promises I make I make very seriously.
So that's good and it's bad. It means
that I hesitate to make big promises
that might create the possibility that the big
thing is going to happen. But on the other hand,
I can live with the confidence of knowing
that you can count on me to keep that promise.
So when I think about what am I going
to do for my next five or 10 year gig,
I think very hard about who am I promising
and what am I promising them? So I can't
say to people what I used to say, which is "We're
renting this theater. Come and, for seven hours,
I will be on stage answering questions. And by
the way, I'm organizing the whole thing with
one volunteer and I'm going to serve you lunch."
That's what I used to do. And 400 people would
come. It was thrilling to stand there for seven
hours and weave together all the answers. If I
announced I was going to do that, I could sell
it, but I couldn't keep that promise for sure.
I don't want to do that because I don't want to,
as my career of a sudden has a different pace,
try to regain my ability to ski at
high speed, not what I'm trying to
do. So where is that sense of community? The
Carbon Almanac was that and continues to be,
but there's going to be another one. And I
think about whether I need it to be in person
or whether this future you and I have been
describing for so long is real and it won't
be in person because I'm very comfortable engaging
with people who aren't sharing the same air as me.
And most of all, is it worth doing for others?
Not, am I just here to entertain myself?
Tim Ferriss: Seth, what else would you like
to talk about here? We can go in a million
directions. What else do you have on here —
Seth Godin: Do you want to talk about —
Tim Ferriss: — on your wooden tiles.
Seth Godin: Okay, so I want to tell the
story of the piano cover at the B conference, and
then I want to talk about meetings. Is that okay?
Tim Ferriss: Sounds great.
Seth Godin: Okay. So I'm about to go on
stage in front of these entrepreneurs, all of whom
have raised far more money than I've ever raised,
all of whom are young whippersnappers who
are going to save the planet. And I've got
no slides or anything. I'm just there at this
beautiful winery north, it's like Yountville
or Booneville or something. And —
Tim Ferriss: This is in Australia
or somewhere else?
Seth Godin: No, no,
I haven't been to Australia in a long time. This
is north of San Francisco and I need a shtick.
I need some anecdote to get started. And off to
the side is a piano in one of those quilted piano
covers. Can you visualize that?
Tim Ferriss: I can.
Seth Godin: They have those special custom
made piano covers and on top of the piano
is one of those little metal things that
says "Do not place anything on top of this."
And on top of that is the sign, but I can't
read the sign, so I walk over because that's
going to be my shtick, which is, "Did you ever
notice that people put a 'Do not…' and then put
a sign on top of that?" And on the sign that
says, "This is the original Steinway Grand D
piano" — not an original, the original from 1884.
And I had my story, I went over and I said,
"The folks who built that Steinway in
1884 had no idea that 140 years later
it would be working, it would be creating magic,
and we would be talking about it." And I said,
"There's no guarantee that what we do is going
to be around in 140 years, but we could act like
it might be, we could say this thing we're doing
together is not to say, how do we raise as much
money as we can? Or how do we get written up well
on this blog site or whatever. It's important."
And there are lots of kinds of important, it
could be important to one person, it could be
important a century from now. But this idea that
the piano is still here, just it gave me chills.
Tim Ferriss: I love that. The piano cover,
that is wild too. The original. What
an experience just to be able to touch
something like that or be close to it. Wild.
Seth Godin: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So meetings?
Seth Godin: Meetings. I have been obsessed
with these for a long time and have lived
a different path for meetings.
Our friend Tobi at Shopify
wrote a script that deleted every group meeting
that was regularly scheduled in the whole company,
and then the next day sent an email to everyone
in the company and said, "I just bought you back
your day." Because if you have 10,000 employees,
and there are all these weekly or daily meetings,
we're talking about tens of millions of
dollars of wasted time. But on top of that,
we're talking about the innovating brain
deadening idea of watching someone talk
because they couldn't care enough to
take the time to send a memo instead,
or couldn't care enough to just record a 10-minute
video and send it to everyone to watch as many
times as they wanted, slower, faster, read
the transcript and then get back to them.
And Tobi said, "If you really need the meeting,
go ahead and put it back on your calendar. You're
welcome." And what meetings have become. So
Zoom is a miracle because Zoom eliminates
geography when it comes to being able to connect
with people. And memos were a miracle because
they eliminated time, they're asynchronous. And
when we add video to this, what we get is either
we're going to have everyone get
together for an hour so I can talk at you
and I can take attendance based on you sitting
there. And what we know from surveys is people
hate this. It's one of the things they hate the
most about their day. And it's a form of power,
authority, status, and control. So conversations
need to happen. More meetings need to happen
never. You can have conversations all day. You
can have a two-minute conversation, a six-minute
conversation, talk to this person or that person.
But a conversation means there are questions
and there are answers. People are talking to
each other. Everyone is changed. At the end,
a meeting is a delivery of information for
the convenience of the person who called it.
And I think it is possible. I know it is
possible. We never once had a meeting the
whole time we built The Carbon Almanac. There
were times I sent a video to people and said,
"This is what's up. Watch it if you want to." But
because we were in time zones around the world,
a meeting wouldn't have made any sense. We had
things where I said, "I'm having office hours,
you can come ask questions," but I didn't do
that other thing. And it feels to me like the
future of the resilient organization is a
lot closer to what Matt does at Automattic,
which is how do we build this asynchronous
geography free institution that doesn't
depend on me making stuff up while I'm on camera.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely. And for people who may
not have caught his name before, Matt Mullenweg
is his name. He's been on this podcast a number of
times, and he also has been part of a podcast.
And this is, I believe, Automattic produced,
called Distributed. I may be getting the name
wrong, but it is entirely about distributed
organizations in unorthodox ways of approaching
the type of thing that we're discussing right now,
meetings or lack thereof, different means
of communication, et cetera. And he's been
distributed first for a very, very, very long
time. So yeah, they were incredibly prepared,
albeit coincidentally for everything
that happened during lockdown and so on.
Seth Godin: Well, but coincidentally,
everyone else was unprepared. Have you
seen what his team has built with ChatGPT
for blogs? Has he shown you the version yet?
Tim Ferriss: I don't know if it's
public. I have seen screenshots,
but yeah. Is it public? I don't know.
Seth Godin: It's not public, but we're only
talking, so we're allowed to talk.
Tim Ferriss: Okay,
go for it. So if you want to talk —
Seth Godin: I was going to say it is
the single best use I have seen of ChatGPT or
whatever they're using, being implemented in a
way where it's not just a talking llama,
it's actually, "Oh yeah, I need this."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, for sure. They
create some amazing products. So yes,
that'll be the teaser. The teaser for people.
Seth Godin: I'm just here for the hype.
Tim Ferriss: There's good things to come. Right.
That's what I think when I say that, when I think
South Dakota. Oh, Seth, is there anything else
you would like to chat about before we begin to —
Seth Godin: Your listeners love tips. I've got
one last tactic tip that changed the lives of a
lot of people. And then we'll do the magical wrap
up stuff. We invented something called page 19
thinking, and we knew there was going to be page
19 of the Almanac. It was going to be written,
copy, edited, illustrated type, set, footnoted.
But there wasn't one person on our team who knew
how to make page 19. And so we said to the team,
"We know in the future there will be a page 19.
We know that it will come from this group, but we
also know there's not anyone here who's qualified,
so what should we do?" And the answer is someone
should write a paragraph of page 19 and say,
"Please make this better." And then someone else
will add to that and someone else will footnote
that and someone else will illustrate that.
And we will relentlessly criticize page 19
without one saying, "The person who worked on it
was wrong or incompetent." And page 19 thinking,
I've always had page 19 thinking, I didn't need
it. But so many people when they heard this
felt the freedom to now speak up and contribute
because they knew it was going to get better. And
if you think about it, that's Apple, that's Ford.
That's every company you can name, right? Sergey
did not program the Google you are using today. It
started with a little, tiny German and someone and
someone and someone and someone and someone, when
you feel stuck, just look for page 19 thinking.
Tim Ferriss: And is the way to look for
page 19 thinking, to take the pressure off
by lowering your expectations in a sense so
that you can iterate your way to excellence.
Is this applicable to a solo shop or a very small
shop? Could you maybe elaborate on what you mean,
what it could mean, to embrace that?
Seth Godin: It puts the pressure on.
It doesn't need the pressure off. It puts the
pressure on. Because you can no longer be a prima
donna who says, "Ah, I don't, I'm afraid someone's
going to punch me in the nose." Because you have
to say, "My nose is not involved." Right? And I
heard Danny's great story about my nose, and it
made me smile. He offered —
Tim Ferriss: This is Danny Meyer,
folks, for people who don't know.
Seth Godin: After he broke my nose,
he offered to straighten it out. And as you
can see in the video, it's still crooked. But
once you understand that you live in a page 19
world, the pressure is on for you to put out work
that can generously be criticized. Don't ship
junk, not allowed, but create the conditions
for the thing you're noodling on to become
real. That doesn't happen by you hoarding
it until it's perfect. It happens by you
creating a process for it to get better.
So now you're on the hook. Fish don't like to
be on the hook. People should be on the hook.
Tim Ferriss: I love it. And I was thinking
of how this might apply to my own, and I have
since we last spoke, been writing fiction
and shipping fiction. I'm not saying it's
Ursula K. Le Guin, but I'm, I'm happy with it. I
am on the hook and have tried to create, I haven't
found exactly what I think will be most helpful
later, but to create an environment in which
perfect is not the enemy of good, but that
I also have a means of not shipping garbage
and actually having people review my work. How do
you like to solicit feedback on writing? This is,
I know a tangent, but if you reach out to
people to proofread or review drafts of
something you've put together, how do you
enable them to be the best proofreaders?
Seth Godin: Three words, and then
some definitions. The three words are:
criticism, feedback, and advice. I'm terrible at
criticism. Don't like criticism. I'm okay with —
Tim Ferriss: You're terrible at receiving it.
Seth Godin: Receiving it, yeah. I like criticizing
people. Yeah, no problem. But
being criticized, not my thing.
Good feedback is precious. But advice, advice
I can handle because advice is one human who's
on the side of the other human helping them
turn on lights. Now, when it comes to writing,
there is line editing, copyediting, developmental
editing, and proofreading. They do not mean the
same thing. Proofreading means did the changes
that were instructed to be made get made.
So proofreading is sort of trivial. Copyediting
says, "What do you think about the Oxford comma?"
Copyediting says, "I don't like the
way you spelled this kind of thing."
Line editing says this sentence would be
better if you moved the second half to
the first half that I'm going to smooth your
voice up. And developmental editing is magic.
I read your work. Let's just talk in general
about the change you seek to make and why it
could be made better in a different way. So
I work with the magical Nicki Papadopoulos at
Penguin mostly because her developmental
editing is the best I've ever encountered.
She says "The title of the book is wrong and you
need to move these three chapters to the end."
What's that worth? That's spectacular. But
I will confess, if she's not listening, that
before I send her a book, I send it to a paid copy
editor who works for me. I don't work for him.
And for $1,000, he copyedits the book. So
he is not allowed to change any of my voice,
but he fixes every one of the little things.
So when I send it to Penguin, they think, "Wow,
this guy's so good at all the detail." No,
I'm not, Dr. Aker is, but you don't know he
exists because I send it to him before I send
it to you. So the point is, you will run into
people who think that the most important thing
they can tell you is you're missing a comma in
the third line. This is not helpful. This work is
now cheap. It's free online. You can just upload
a file and someone will fix it for you. But
developmental editors, they're priceless. You
need to find someone who has that as a skill.
Opinions don't matter. That's why the whole
thing with logos — don't show anybody your
logo and don't tell anybody your new kid's
name before they're born, because everyone
thinks they have an opinion about a logo,
but no one's got expertise. It's none of their
business. Pick your logo and do your logo. The
same thing's true with your kid's name. And
when you show your writing to an amateur,
they're going to give you logo advice. It's the
book isn't for them. You need to engage with
people who the book is for, watch what they do
with it. See what lights them up. So in my case,
after Permission Marketing, hearing people say
back to me which parts of the book resonated with
them taught me how to write the next book because
I didn't ask anybody, "How do I make this book
better?" I just said, "I wrote this book," and
seeing what they did, I gave them more of that.
Tim Ferriss: Right? By extension, the Zig
could have taken the fact that you know the
overall story word for word and be like, "Okay,
interesting. Let's take a look at why that worked,
and maybe I'll give him an extra
heaping dose of something like the
overall story in the next book."
Seth Godin: Exactly. And I know
for a fact that that's exactly what Zig did.
Tim Ferriss: So Seth, the new book is The Song of
Significance, subtitle, A New Manifesto for Teams.
People can find you at sethgodin.com, seth.blog.
Is there anything else you would like to
add? Any requests you would like to make
of my audience? Any complaints you'd like to
lodge formally, criticisms maybe, or anything
else you would like to say before we wrap up?
Seth Godin: I am overwhelmed with gratitude
that I get to do this, and I am feeling
the murmurs of generosity and abundance,
replacing the small minded scarcity that was
so common for so long as people hustled their
way through one thing after another over the last
bunch of years. And I think as we all come out of,
hopefully come out of this worldwide pandemic,
people are taking a deep breath and focusing on
contribution and generosity. And all I can tell
you is I'm overwhelmed with gratitude for you and
for the people who support my work, just making
things better. Because if not that, what? So
Tim Ferriss: Thank you. Thank you so much, Seth.
And to everybody listening, we'll have everything
that we discussed in the show notes and
probably quite a bit more at tim.blog/podcast
where you can find this and show notes on
every other episode. And until next time,
just to be a bit nicer than is necessary to
yourself and to other people, make things just
a bit better. Have that extra conversation. Say
that extra nice word. Do what you can. It doesn't
have to be huge. Probably shouldn't be huge,
because then you can hide behind that as we've
covered previous episodes. Make it small, make it
matter. And until next time, thanks for tuning in.